SPEAKER: In our last episode,
we covered ingesting, routing,
storing, and viewing logs from
your services in Cloud Logging.
But what else can you
do with all that data?
Today, I'm going
to show you how you
can use Cloud Logging to
further improve your ability
to keep your services reliable
with features like alerting
in logs, logs-based metrics,
and capturing application
exceptions in error reporting.
Welcome to "Engineering for
Reliability with Google Cloud."
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Let's say you are running
a production environment
and you need to know if
any modifications are
made to the IAM configuration
for this project.
These changes will
show up in audit logs,
but you don't
really want to sift
through those to figure out when
something like this happens.
You could set up a
rudimentary log processing
pipeline with Cloud Functions,
but now there's an easier way.
Let's have a look at how to
use the new log-based alerts
in Cloud Logging.
From the dashboard, go
to the Products menu.
And from Logging,
select Logs Explorer.
We want to find all logs that
show changes in IAM policies.
That's easy enough to do
with using recent queries.
Once we have the logs
we want to alert on,
we can use the Actions
button to create a log alert.
Let's name our alert
and add any information
we want to send with the alert.
Next, let's confirm
our logs query.
Then, let's set the minimum
time between notifications
to be as frequent as we'd like.
Finally, let's specify
the notification channel
and save the alert.
The alerting policy
has been created,
and we are ready to test it.
If an IAM policy change is
made, we can go back to logging
and rerun the query to see that
more entries matching our query
are available.
From there, we can go to
Monitoring and select Alerting.
There's a current incident
based on the alerting policy
we created.
We can select the
incident to confirm
that we have a log query match
that triggered our condition.
We can click View Logs to
see the logs that generated
the match and the alert.
So that's how you can use
log-based alert policies
to be notified when,
for example, there's
a change in IAM configuration
in your project.
Now, alerting in logs is great.
But what if you want to know how
many times something like this
happens?
Or what if the log
payloads have data in them
that you'd like to
measure over time?
This is where logs-based
metrics come in.
You can configure
a counter metric
to measure the permanent
rate of log entries
that match a query or
a distribution metric
to capture numeric values
from login to payloads.
Let's have a look
at how to set up
a counter metric
in Cloud Logging
and use it in Cloud Monitoring.
Let's create a metric
to count requests
to our service running
on App Engine labeled
by response code.
Let's go to the Logs Explorer
and select our Google App
Engine application.
Let's select an entry that
shows an App Engine request
and use Show Matching Entries
to get all the logs that
look like what we
want to include
as a source for our metric.
We'll again use
the Actions button,
but this time we'll
create a metric.
We'll select Counter
as the metric type
and name our metric.
Next, we'll confirm the filter
and add a label to our metric
that will allow us to separate
request counts by status.
Finally, let's save the metric.
Now, when we go to
log-based metrics,
we can see our metric here.
Once a metric is created
and gathering data,
we can use it like any
other monitoring metric.
We can view it in
Metrics Explorer,
we can use it for
charts and dashboards,
and we can even create alerts
using it in a condition.
So that's how you can use
a counter log-based metric
to count App Engine requests
labeled by response code
status.
We've now seen how
to get alerts on logs
and how to use them
to create metrics.
The last thing I
want to show you
is how to use error reporting
to count, analyze, and aggregate
the crashes in your
running Cloud Services.
Let's have a look.
From the Products menu,
go to Error Reporting.
The initial screen shows you
a summary of all the errors
that have been seen in your
project over the selected time
interval.
You can click on an error to
get more information about it.
The histogram will
show you how frequently
this error has occurred.
Further down, you can see the
parsed and raw stack traces
and the specific
samples of the error.
You can even view the
logs that generated
that particular sample.
By viewing the logs
for the sample,
you can see information about
where the error originated.
Here we can see the
GKE cluster, namespace,
and container that threw
this particular exception.
So error reporting
is a great way
to see application
exceptions in your services
and quickly figure out
when they're happening
and where they're coming from.
Services running on
App Engine or Cloud Run
send errors to error
reporting automatically.
You can send errors
from other applications
to error reporting
by logging into Cloud
Logging in a format
recognizable by error reporting,
or by using the error
reporting API directly.
Refer to the
documentation for details
on both of those options.
Thanks for joining me today.
We covered alerting
on log entries,
using logs-based metrics
to count and aggregate log
entries, and using
error reporting
to track application crashes.
I hope these features help you
find issues faster and keep
your services reliable
and your users happy.
Thanks so much for watching.
Don't forget to like and
subscribe to never miss out
on more "Engineering for
Reliability with Google Cloud."
See you soon.
[MUSIC PLAYING]